what's up gamers now that I'm 30 I'm
officially a Boomer that's why I brought
in boomer expert well now it is I
exactly know gee feel just taste so much
better once he hit 30 mm-hmm
stay in your lane October November
December oh it's because Christmas
starts earlier and earlier it pisses me
off yes yes y-yeah Cranky's music in
October
what oh it's so stupid stinky Instagram
influencers I just wants to post about
likes and Instagram and they want it for
free they want everything for they want
everything for free and oh my god they
think it's a real job it's weird though
I do agree with the whole they want
everything they're so entitled
my gonna get things for free already
angry it just pissed me off when like
it's Halloween and I see people post
about this Christmas yeah I should be
illegal like I would love to send people
to jail if they do they just so they
know to jail yeah I agree I agree oh
this is a good look have you seen that
art style of this is amazed I haven't
seen it you just know it from the art
style yeah it's a problem or a Boomer
who made this yeah
your pops you should get a Wi-Fi box box
I love that because that's like already
no one calls it a Wi-Fi box yeah that's
that's pretty crazy
I already have a Wi-Fi a wife I
oh yeah yeah boomers hate their wife
more than anything I'm not there yet but
I I think in a couple of years mm-hmm
you gotta work up that resentment yeah
you really had it why for like a couple
months yeah I had a wife I for a long
time then your wife's box okay do
whatever the guy next to you always
looks in his pocket before he orders a
shot interesting
do you want another shot sure another
whiskey please
a few minutes later it looks like I'll
take another shot of whiskey I'm curious
why do you look into your pocket before
ordering each shot I have a picture of
my wife in there and when she starts to
look good I go home I hate my wife my
wife's bad that's the title I said a
nice thing boomers hate their wives
where does that come from I feel like
it's like old comic yeah yeah yeah
second do you remember when every sitcom
was like a bar like yeah and oh yeah oh
my god what is that one with the owl
yeah yeah I know exactly which one that
was a call National Society of men
against Amazonian masterhood why do I
remember that no ma'am it was called do
remember that no ma'am he should be the
boomer ahead of boomer he hates his wife
yeah yeah basically the whole show was
based on like him being a macho man and
he hated my wife he doesn't like women
what does a Boomer one woman then I
guess just like just hating mutes and
maybe hating your husband yeah if you're
a Boomer allowing like just let us know
like worry we're inclusive boomers yeah
let us know about how much you hate your
husband's I think phone bad it's a
really like woman thing
yeah phone bad computer bad
yeah video game band it's election day
in Canada it's my Boomer online I have a
Boomer on - I love her though okay let's
see let's talk more action we can make a
difference youth were change people who
change we can make a difference making a
real difference is this way voting the
youth they don't just March it's so true
I kind of agree with me but like they do
though the people go in those marches
will be voting that's true it's like
that's true but I think I feel like if
you remove the vote and you just change
that to be like making a difference yeah
more like with like the Facebook
posturing and yeah like just by changing
my profile picture to this this way the
posturing yeah that's what it sumers
love to do more than anything
oh you like self-worth huh find a real
job Circle bet you don't know how to
screw screw you just you don't do you
know busy looking on your iPad yes
change the light bulb oh ha ha
cheating where the neighbor okay dead
what's difference between confident and
confidential hmm you are my son of that
I am confident your friend Billy next
door is also my son that's confidential
how many did you catch Oh
like with my funk in there can you
afford it
why can't you do did phone man it's
another example of these is like when
Zoomers defend the phone they're like oh
my god the phone is an amazing device
that can let you look up anything in the
world but you can't do that with the
dictionary like it's the same thing will
I vote for them are cringing yeah but
the thing is they're not looking up like
important stuff on their phone yeah
exactly yeah you just looking at ready
[Laughter]
humor well-written structured original
joke and boomers are like not reacting
right when a movie has to joke about
teens not knowing what a VHS tape boomer
time over time it's so true I mean I
can't it was funny the first time okay
they take photo of baby they take photo
baby they took photo child and he wrote
me Mom and Dad he thinks they're self oh
oh they're not living in the moment
like we did when we were kids do you
remember look uh do you remember feeling
while you didn't want to be reachable
all the time when you like got a cell
phone I felt like getting a spell phone
kind of sucked in the beginning because
it meant like my dad could call me yeah
you're right yeah you couldn't that's it
yeah this is a Boomer moment here I feel
like we're sharing yeah great yeah it's
like I don't know because before that
you can't like to tell your parents you
did like anything you just go yeah
everyone yeah you're right and now it's
a signal collie at any time and you'd
have to be like okay guys shut up and
then all your friends but like oh he's
freaking a P P yeah I did that in years
once we were firing up Rockets uh-huh
and then my mom called me and I was like
I got an answer and then I'm like I hope
they don't like explode the fireworks
and she's like are you stupid cellphones
boo don't like phone band yeah phone bad
boomer good yes and there's so many good
things about phones now I know so my
parents have
do not call me almost a 31 years old so
you know you finally figured out we just
get old enough guys and it's fine if
anyone objects to this union oh my bad
already bad just getting married and
already bad when are you why are you
getting married then exactly
damn it mom I told you hundred dad
there's no way to pause an online game
[Music]
ooh more time yeah but you don't know
what to do now don't need to pause in
the line game if you're not playing in a
line game am i right boomer friends I
hope you have a lot of boomers watching
us I have some old people yeah that's
good good it's much like if you're a
boomer yes
smash like if you're Zoomer so we can
know one thing my mom would always do
when I was at the computer and had the
TV on in the back she was like one has
to go oh any parents ever do that no I
never understood it because I'm like -
because I'm listening to the TV I don't
need to watch the TV mom mom our mutual
friend who we kinda like met through
Anton he was the first guy I saw doing
that and I was actually like what are
you doing how do you do the same two
things at once yeah so you're you were a
Boomer before I always a Boomer before
it was cool but now it's really beta
there's a life beyond Facebook really
please share the link to it oh they're
always what links music sure has changed
a lot like how well for starters singers
actually used to sing oh this is for you
like you know I feel like my stands you
know my videos just like that people can
do whatever they want it's like I would
tell you look you really photoshopped
your thumbnails dude yeah why don't you
just take a good picture and we'll just
take one photo yeah
just like we used I mean that's a Boomer
thing I feel like I miss just being able
to take
one photo mm-hmm you just have to take
so many now yeah it's because we're
getting uglier - that's true yeah boomer
ugly we have to get the right angle
yeah weird look that someone printed out
a bunch of tweets and then they added
extra characters to all the words
[Music]
without a single degree they built us
roads that have lasted an eternity and
then the engineers arrived bad modern
signs bad oh stop it good that's what
I'm saying these roads did not exist in
the Roman Empire my god Loki it is kind
of impressive how they built at the same
time like do you think it always looked
like this like this is a drawing and
that's a photo yeah well there's roads
now that look good too I'm just saying
no boomer I mean that is impressive
yeah you know I guess it hasn't been
used by actual cars though now exactly
mm back in my day I didn't have to
accept privacy policies mm-hmm I've made
it worse
2,000 year old Roman Road two year old
modern and hey I'll print this one oh
well you haven't shared any boomer
coming some Facebook yeah I don't have a
Facebook
when washer stops remove all your
clients Alexandra will cassia Cortez
goes to the laundromat she's a liberal
she's an idiot
oh yeah she's all wrong I got so upset
in my video when I found out inherence
tax is 40%
oh really yeah and it generally pissed
me off home dad that's boomer do you
have gluten-free treats lady I'm lactose
intolerant I can't eat nuts
do you have vegan chocolate me organic
only
have no good allergy gender-neutral can
be gender-neutral yeah haha I mean
you're gonna have your last one but the
rest I'm like yeah come on it's so
individualistic now everyone has their
own little special thing it gets
annoying why are we discussing this I
wanna do because we're boomers okay
let's discuss okay so she shouldn't have
to have all those different types of
candy yeah but like lactose intolerant
then you can eat like gummies she
probably has gummies in there yeah
surely and like I can't eat nuts that's
yeah how dare you know okay nuts it's
not bad annoying to get used to see
that's why it's boomer yeah we don't
want to change okay you can have another
spin but only crusted see Herbert what I
have this a lot birthday that's an epic
30 year old grass type of drawing as
well it's like Gilbert is yeah so bad
I'm sorry I have to let you all go but
you're just not freaks anymore haha
now everyone is crazy
everyone's like this like a lot of girls
now with beards girls have beards now
people are like what's up with that I'm
a Boomer people are big now yeah people
people have fat and about it some people
have some tattoos now too crazy yes
back in my day back in my day no one had
a tattoo no one looked different
everyone the same clever and original
millennial humour I hate my life
Quincy and bad boomer humor I hate my Y
that is true I hate my life is just as
cringy yeah we need a guy equals life my
your wife is your life I've been
separated from my parents because of
Trump's Nazi border policy right no they
got caught with plastering straw oh the
camera like oh my god she crazy - crazy
just like a crazy liberal guy stinky
piercings and yeah they don't they don't
understand these court don't understand
anything
all right isn't that plastic straw thing
like a bit of an overreaction yeah not
more important issues to solve yeah than
plastic straws like it's like people saw
that one photo but turtle and everyone's
like oh my god we have to stop using
that yeah it's all fiscal girl thing
right one that's all visco girl thing
right disco girl oh my god you don't
know busy I thought it was the only one
who didn't know what a visco girl is
what is that it's like one of the news
like subcultures it's like the girls
that I like wearing they have like the
hydro flask and they say and they say
and I heard this yeah this goes like in
photo editing app it's become like a
subculture I've been seeing some words
in my comments that I need to ask you
all about so like visco girl
I don't know that's the SEO girl or
disco girl or schist kiss-kiss have no
idea what the hell that is
and one there's one that says and I hope
I got a feeling that somehow knows this
is a way inappropriate so you're
probably getting a really big food out
of this so let me know I don't get it
though I still don't understand what's
funny about it it's not funny it's just
like an actual subculture like I never
seen it is this normal white girls I
don't get it
it is like a white girls that's what I
don't understand
explain it but I can't explain it man
it's too complex I don't get it
oh is it like amber Chamberlain is that
it I think it's kind of image handling
yeah but I guess he did a video about
she already done a video yeah no no no
nurse I said slip off his testicles
spectacles spectacle blonde with big
tits dumb yeah you can't be blonde and
attractive it and have any brain no this
is how that works now that's a Boomer
sentiment yeah I swear people tried to
make me think that when I was a kid yeah
attractive people were automatically
suited or really buff people too right
yeah yeah this I wonder what boomer
values you still have it you don't
realize yeah yeah shaped by society
I think Burma's forget that washing
machines and dryers were invented during
their lifetime because all they cared
about was making their own daily lives
easier it tries to washing using the
very latest technology a combination of
solar and wind power
she says wasn't their thing we're like
the the dishwasher was actually a really
important invention for the women to be
out of the kitchen yeah and here boomers
are like Oh
we're just wind oh you can wash your
dishes with your hands yeah yeah such
backward-thinking yes technology bad is
probably the worst boomer value yeah
although well we have all these taken
howl idea right but like is anyone
happier from it I was talking to someone
about this the other day have you
thought about how much easier it's like
sleep around now because of like the
apps and stuff compared like only people
who were really I don't sleep around Joe
I know guys my tinder no but I just
thought about that how like that's gotta
have made it easier for people want to
do that I don't know that's like yeah
you can argue it's a broom about you to
feel that's not a good thing to be like
it's too easy to hook up now yeah I
think you had to be like good in like
club since oh yeah yeah and now you can
find someone on your same page yeah
easier yeah this one was born without an
umbilical cord it's because he's from
the wireless generation the police just
pulled me over him and said papers I
said scissors I win and drove off I
think he wants a rematch
he's been my English textbook is
terrible I'm hitting a nail I'm hitting
it again I'm hitting it a third time
things would move much quicker if you
didn't tweet every nail feelings if we
do it every stroke he's tweeting he's
three thing to doing everyone all right
okay millennial dad's have terrible DIY
skills half of them own don't own a
stepladder cordless drill half don't
have a cordless drill your dad oh you're
right when you were dad probably and
you're never set of screwdrivers
what bothers me yes again someone to do
it I that's what I do was the time yeah
so you'll be that millennial dad huh
proud millennial dad yeah I feel like
it's so embarrassing though when you get
someone there and it's literally like
two seconds and it's done mm-hmm because
you don't know like the basic thing to
do so I actually in my old flat I used
to actually get a guy in to change the
light box so you're not a Boomer at all
I'm just old zoomer is like the thing is
there was like a light over the stairs
oh yeah you don't own a step line but
then once it was there once he was there
like so where do kids learn to be so
violent and that one's real I mean like
that's a real comic yeah it's so yeah
that's like one of those boomer ideas
that just seems too sick for some reason
it's like it's been disproved like
scientifically so many times it just
doesn't seem to stick no yes like
violence did not exist before movies
yeah balances come down but kids are
playing video games so video games bad
video game bad like what's he has like a
bomb in the house I guess yeah what's
yeah I mean if yeah if you let your kid
have a bomb in the house or like
whatever them I got your rating to
answer why is he so ugly yeah the kid
looks like an a dog yeah it's got like
like this but I feel I gotta say I feel
like it's again it's equally cringy when
kids be like no but this is car video
games at all no I don't think it's asked
when you when you've got science on your
side but yeah I still think it's cringy
like overtly trying oh yeah you do it
like really great I think it's just
cause buyers at oh you're all
scientifically wrong like who cares
could you see that like some stores
stopped selling like video games after
like a shooting and stuff okay yeah
that's I think I think it when I read it
it was when
Trump said something and then everyone
on Twitter be like I've played video
games my whole life I never thought of
doing anything violence that's like yeah
it's more like how you say it I guess
then yeah that's a good point yeah cuz
then you're putting yourself into it and
be like I'm so good I'm not bad at all
this is so great you're right classical
music good modern bed
Joe Han you have to come with me to 2018
we have to save the word from each awful
electronic dance music box to the fuse
[Laughter]
is music better back in the day no you
listen to the top charge yeah I do yeah
what's wrong with come on say yeah what
saying say what was awesome ariana
grande is shocked Bach was awesome
ariana grande and Sun people can't leave
without their phone phone bad please do
not panic you're only required to turn
off your mobile staring the movie is it
weird that I always feel like just like
turning off my phone didn't know that
yeah man did you turn yours off when we
saw Joker yeah yeah but you feel anxious
about doing it yeah why I don't know I
feel like something bad is gonna happen
when I'm disconnected
you're also one of the people who like
really bad things have happened to you
I've never had like a moment let's share
honey what's the password our
anniversary date she did this on purpose
what's your anniversary date nineteen
Morris think of them as shoes get women
buy shoes women buy shoes men buy island
goodbye son
that's our bus go to die there's no
Wi-Fi and there's only ugly wife
revolution your generation girls like a
guy with a cigarette too like he's so
cool oh yeah very well to be fair silver
white coloring the tasteful paranoid oh
my god
it even has embossed surface he's
talking about this one that tastes like
garbage you're right well this has been
insightful I learned a lot about myself
I guess I share a lot more with the
boomers than I thought I guess it just
comes from being 30 are you sure you're
30 I am 31 but not married yet oh yeah I
guess that's why I'm more boomerang and
I feel like you're closer to retirement
yeah maybe you you thought about it you
thought about it we time every single
day all right well thanks for coming on
Joel check out roomie thank you
you makes auto-tune bad altitude bad
real singing good yeah hey bro
ready bro well you haven't tried to
pursue me later City after 50 million
our troops much I am don't just doubt
it's still relevant just a love it